bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france votre votre état
d'esprit vous à l'issue de cette journée
qui n'est pas encore terminé de
mobilisation dans toute la france contre
les lois dites liberticide sans avoir pu
prendre part aux manifestations
d'aujourd'hui je constate que voilà on a
repris une certaine un certain fil rouge
dès samedi avec toute la population en
plusieurs catégories pas mal de jeunes
comme il a été dit juste avant et que
voilà ça s'installe alors c'est quand
c'est toi sécurité globale mais pas
uniquement ses conçoit la politique en
général de deux macron nous moi je suis
gilet jaune avec le gilet jaune en a
manifesté le 17 novembre pour aller deux
ans du mouvement et c'était sous les
fenêtres de l'assemblée avec des
policiers contre cette loi déjà
donc je suis ravi qu'il ya un maximum de
gens qui se mobilisent que ça la joie
les images en même temps voilà c'était
1-1 79 interpellations sur un trajet qui
était relativement court j'aimerais bien
savoir qui sont les interpeller qu'il
est le profil des interpellés parce que
sur la base de mon expérience des
précédentes manifestations
c'est pas toujours ce que la police soit
sans rechercher qui finissent dans le
panier à salade à la fin voilà alors
vous êtes gilet jaune
il ya eu je jouerai je répète cette
question parce que je vais déjà posé
deux fois mais à une manifestation d
gilet jaune qui était interdite
aujourd'hui voilà on entendait jérôme
rodriguez interdite pour des raisons
sanitaires mais aussi pour les risques
sérieux de troubles à l'ordre public
alors que cette marche contre les lois
liberticides
elle a été autorisée par la préfecture
de police votre sentiment là-dessus
ce n'a pas grand sens toute façon les
gens qui sont partout ils seront partout
là où il ya une manifestation déclarée
même si la déclare pas s'il ya une
interdiction de de toute manifestation
on va retrouver dans des rassemblements
sauvages non déclarés les gilles et je
ne sais pas
un mouvement comme on a pu en connaître
avant avec des frontières qui mobilise
seulement certaines catégories certaines
corporations ou certaines classes d'âge
c'est vraiment global donc on retrouvera
partout ils pourront interdire toutes
les manifestations est empilé estampillé
gilet jaune qu'ils veulent au final ça
ne changera pas grand chose il va
falloir qu'ils s'attaquent un peu plus
haut au droit de manifester lui même ce
qu'ils ont déjà commencé à faire depuis
quelques temps comme votre précédente
invité le signalait et c'est ça
effectivement qui qui est grave et il ya
plusieurs manières de s'attaquer au
droit de manifester il ya le fait de ne
pas accepter des déclarations le fait de
refuser que des manifestations se
tiennent mais il ya aussi du grabuge qui
peut y avoir un rassemblement et comment
la police décide de le traiter ou de ne
pas le traiter
donc voyez vous ce que vous sentez
disait que le mouvement des gilet jaune
doit se sentir visés par la préfecture
de police les autorités ministère de
l'intérieur ben on se sent visé par eux
depuis le tout début et depuis le jour 1
donc oui ici s'il n'avait pu nous nous
étouffer intégralement il l'aurait fait
ils ont tenté par beaucoup de moyens on
sait qu'on est toujours dans leur
collimateur
on sait que là il y avait des des notes
de ddr j'ai des notes de stratégie de
renseignement qui donnait la part belle
au gilet jaune tout de suite après le
l'aspect terrorisme voilà ils sont sur
nos côtes comme on dit et se méfient ils
ont usé bator de se méfier d'un autre
côté alors il ya beaucoup de colère dans
ce contexte aussi de crises sanitaires
au regard des des mesures de
restrictions qui sont prises par les
autorités dans tous les secteurs vous
êtes vous mêmes entrepreneurs justement
comment est ce que vous vivez cette
situation moitié de personnages ces
entrepreneurs dans l'événementiel donc
autant vous dire que c'est un secteur
qui est vraiment très très très durement
attaqué par l'est les mesures sanitaires
par la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement
ils nous promettent des aides qu'on voit
pas toujours arriver on voit arriver un
peu mais vraiment loin de ce qui était
promis
autour de moi j'observe pas mal de
faillite ma société à l'abri pour le
moment mais je dis bien pour le moment
c'est très compliqué il ya ici dur à
accepter des ruines des faillites ça ça
va amener à des suicides pour des
décisions qui sont somme toute absurde
il ya beaucoup de contradictions je vais
pas refaire la liste ici de ce qu on
connait tous sur les tests sur les
masques sur un tas d'autres aspects de
cette crise les insuffisances du
gouvernement ces mensonges mais surtout
ses décisions absurdes
je pense au grand place qui se passe
dans l'est dans les stations de ski etc
s'est jamais anodin quand un
gouvernement soi-disant des litres de
gens qui ont fait des études qui sont
très très intelligent se met à prendre
des décisions comme ça aussi absurde et
en les assumant totalement c'est
toujours le signe avant coureur d'un
d'un processus totalitaire et ça va avec
se disait tout à l'heure sur sur le
droit de manifester et toutes les
libertés publiques qui sont mises en
danger depuis plusieurs années donc vous
vous donner un sens qui va au delà de la
lutte contre les lois dites liberticide
aujourd'hui notamment les derniers
samedis aussi que l'on a pu observer
vous êtes l'auteur du livre vers la
révolution il ya une convergence hong
kong
ça revient souvent ce terme la
convergence des luttes ça va donner quoi
après les fêtes
cette possible convergence des luttes
entre ceux qui sont en colère par
rapport à la créa la gestion de la crise
sanitaire aux mesures de restriction
ceux qui sont en colère aussi vis-à-vis
des lois au qu'ils jugent liberticide
alors c'est une convergence qui est pas
très évidente à est très facile à
théoriser mais elle est très difficile à
faire
en tous les cas sur le papier c'est
quelque chose qui se fait avec les
circonstances généralement c'est la
contre-révolution qui fait la révolution
cr sont les abus du gouvernement en
place qui sou sans que puisse entrer
dans une impunité totale
mettez vous à la place d'emmanuel macron
dans sa tête lui le soir quand il
s'endort il a vaincu les gille et joli
mais celui qui a survécu au mouvement
social qui a réussi à passer tout ce
qu'il avait prévu de passer ou presque
avec le concours des médias avec le
concours d'une mince frange de la
population et donc ils abusent et on
pourrait se dire que il viendrait quand
même avec les années à une certaine
forme de sagesse et en fait pas du tout
il continue et cette loi sécurité
globale par exemple n'était pas
forcément nécessaire
c'est cet actif 24 période c'est une
chose de dire qu'on interdit de filmer
mais si une chose d'une autre chose que
de faire vraiment valoir cette
interdiction est d'empêcher des sites
belges ou suisses ou canadiens de
diffuser les images à notre place
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pour nous
nous nous cracher dessus cc je sais pas
comment l'expliquer autrement voilà
c'est du mépris pur et dur et ce mépris
là est très très mal perçu et c'est ce
mépris la qui soudent des groupes qui
pourtant peuvent être rivaux des
catégories qui pourtant n'ont jamais
forcément marcher ensemble qui ont
commencé à marcher ensemble avec le
gilet jaune ensuite avec le mouvement
contrôle et la loi des retraites
le moment aussi de la santé il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sont se sont
coalisés à ce moment là dans la rue et
moi tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que ça va continuer parce que de toute
façon les nouvelles sur le front
économique ne vont être que de pire en
pire créant de nouveaux chômeurs de
nouveaux pauvres de nouveaux
entrepreneurs ruiné qui bat qui n'auront
plus que ça à faire descendre dans la
rue
et pourtant le gouvernement
on met le paquet en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il affirme sur les aides notamment
aux entrepreneurs à tous les acteurs à
économique en cette période de crise
sans guitare comme je disais tout à
l'heure vous partage nos expériences
entre entrepreneurs que ce soit dans le
milieu de la restauration
que ce soit dans l'événementiel dans le
spectacle et est ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que voilà il y as loin de ce
qui est promis à ce qui est vraiment
versé très loin il ya toujours un vice
de forme ya toujours un papier qui
arrive pas il ya toujours un formulaire
qui s'est perdue ou une excuse moi par
exemple j'ai touché des aides pendant
trois mois et ensuite on m'a expliqué
qu'on secteur n'était pas en crise
voilà le secteur événementiel n'était
pas en crise et le message que j'ai reçu
et ça fait quatre mois que je conteste
et que j'attends cette fameuse aide que
d'autres mais on a l'impression que
c'est distribué peu au hasard au petit
bonheur
peut-être à la tête du client j'ose pas
j'espère imaginer ça mais mais en tous
les cas il ya très loin de ce qui est
promis à de ce qui est versé et je vais
vous dire c'est une tradition
gouvernementale quand vous avez une crue
un incendie un tremblement de terre et
que vous avez l'envoyé du gouvernement
qui arrivent nous avons débloqué 300
millions pour gérer cette catastrophe
en fait c'est systématique et des gens
qu'on se des études vont repasser
derrière c'est jamais la somme promise
qui étaient débloqués jamais c'est
toujours la moitié le tiers ça c'est
systématique personne ne va aller faire
le calcul derrière
voyez ces images en direct avec new
fabris crévale donc de la place de la
république
on arrive donc au bout ensemble
vraisembablement de cette dispersion
pour cette journée de mobilisation rien
qu'à paris il ya déjà eu donc des
sommation pour disperser les
manifestants voyez le canon à eau qui
est disposée et en plus donc les
manifestants vers les bouches de métro
pour qu'il quitte donc cette place de la
république on le rappelle également
parce que c'est très important c'est une
journée aussi consacré à la mobilisation
en province
on a manifesté à lille à marseille à
toulouse
une manifestation dont qui se sont
plutôt bien déroulées à paris a eu
quelques heures quand même aux quelques
tensions aujourd'hui mais rien de
comparable avec ce que l'on a pu voir
ces deux dernières semaines les deux
derniers samedis de mobilisation cent
dix neuf interpellations aujourd'hui
selon la préfecture de police
95 la semaine dernière donc il ya eu une
vraie volonté de la part des autorités
aujourd'hui
de prendre le dessus sur le potentiel
risque provoqué par la présence de
profils radicaux de casseurs les black
blocks dont il ya eu beaucoup
d'interpellations un dispositif de
sécurité aussi extrêmement important
pour cette journée
on va le voir dans un instant abonnés va
nous expliquer comment ce dispositif de
sécurité est bien aujourd'hui encadrée
cette journée de mobilisation dans la
capitale
35 unités de forces mobiles et crs
gendarmes 200 policiers de la brave
cette brigade de répression des actions
violentes que l'on voit en action deux
drones également déployé thomas bonnet
j'étais en train de décrire donc le
dispositif sécuritaire parce que c'est
une information importante aujourd'hui
pour pour encadrer cette manifestation
absolument envoyer d'ailleurs on en voit
encore les illustrations à l'heure où je
vous parle avec un important nombre de
pokémon police deux membre de la brave
également avec leurs motos qui sont
stationnés ils ont en fait évacuer la
place de la république maintenant depuis
plusieurs minutes ils ont conduit les
manifestants à à prendre le métro ou à
quitter la place par les rues qui sont
encore empruntables et il ya encore des
contrôles on a vu des personnes encore
être contrôlés entre des camions tout à
l'heure des manifestants on sait pas
vraiment pourquoi évidemment mais en
tout cas on a vu des manifestants est
reconduit vers les camions de police
important dispositif de sécurité donc
aujourd'hui qui a été mise en place pour
cette manifestation alors évidemment
cela a fonctionné leur sens puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de véritable violence dans
cette manifestation contrairement à ce
qu'on avait vu les deux dernières
semaines
mais parallèlement à ça évidemment il ya
un certain nombre de manifestants qui
étaient venus de manière tout à fait
pacifique qui ont été les victimes
collatérales entre guillemets de ces
charges le police qu'on a vu assez
régulièrement
il ne comprenait évidemment pas pourquoi
les forces de l'ordre agissaient de la
sorte voilà donc un peu la tonalité qui
a régné dans les rangs des manifestants
cet après midi si apparaître bonne et
nous intervenons ont parfois souligné
enfin on commentait ces interpellations
l'un des intervenants disait justement
pas certain que ce soit des black blocks
1 qui ont été interpellés vous de ce que
vous avez pu observer sur le terrain
lorsque vous avez suivi cette
manifestation sur le profil des
personnes qui sont interpellés est ce
que vous avez des informations qu est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire
pas réellement d'information sur les
personnes interpellées ce qu'on voit en
tout cas ce qu'on a pu apercevoir c'est
que cette opération était très ciblé
évidemment les membres de la brave
notamment discuté longuement avec leurs
collègues avant d'intervenir dans la
manifestation pour pour bien cibler la
personne qui souhaitait interpeller dont
on imagine qu'ils avaient des raisons
mais évidemment de notre côté en tout
cas aucune information sur le profil des
personnes qui ont été interpellées
merci à thomas bord et alors que l'on
voit ici donc cette bouche de métro
du côté de la république la
manifestation donc qui prend fin avec
cette dispersion et les forces de
l'ordre dont qui pousse les manifestants
à quitter cette place de la république
on est toujours avec fabrice grimal qui
est entrepreneur auteur du livre vers la
révolution fabrice grimal comment vous
voyez l'évolution des prochaines
semaines
de la sorte un peut-être un crescendo
vous dites ou des tout dépendra de du
traitement par les forces de l'ordre du
du mouvement social en général et
et du niveau économique du pays quand on
va annoncer les faillites donc a priori
lloris à ne peut faire qu'augmenter moi
je vois de haut niveau des gilets jaunes
déjà il ya un appel qui promet d'être
très suivie pour le 19 samedi prochain
donc ça y est c'est reparti la seule
chose qui peut nous arrêter c'est leur
confinement total donc on verra bien si
si ça va arriver mais il n'y a pas de
raison que ça change que même avec les
aides dont on parlait le gouvernement
continue notamment d'obéir aux
injonctions de la commission européenne
alors il obéit de bon coeur mais c'est
par exemple dans les grandes
orientations de la commission il est
écrit que toutes mesures d'exception
prises pendant la crise de covin ne
remet pas en cause les recommandations
qui sont par exemple de réduire le
budget de la santé en france d'en donner
une partie au privé et ça commence à
circuler ça commence à se savoir il ya
des gens qui en parlent même dans les
instances européennes comme on parlait
publiquement la contrepartie de tout cet
argent versé
quand même énormément d'argent versé
s'arrête il va falloir le rembourser un
jour tout sauf gratuit et contre
peut-être l'annulation d'une petite
partie
il va falloir payer tout le reste en
vendant tous que l'état possède que ce
soit des infrastructures ou des toutes
les entreprises publiques les monopoles
publics
donc ça a déjà commencé avec le projet
recul le dépeçage d'edf la sncf a déjà
été dépensée à les prêter 2 vendu les
barrages wallace
déjà c'est déjà sur les rails la
française des jeux et tout ce qui a fait
opposition jusqu'à présent les
françaises sont soulevés contre une
décision qu'ils jugent inique du
gouvernement de procéder à ce type de
privatisation il va avoir la
justification du contrecoup de la crise
du coc vite pour le faire et le faire
massivement dans un avenir très produits
et donc ça aussi va cristalliser une
nouvelle opposition les nouvelles
catégories qui je l'espère parce que ils
font toujours l'espérer c'est pas
garanti vont signifier au gouvernement
ce qu'ils en pensent et comme on nous
laisse pas beaucoup de choix notamment
pour ceux qui le reste on se se
contentés des réseaux sociaux viennent
sans sur une censure qui était évidente
qui est manifeste qu'on a des preuves
tous les jours donc il ne reste que la
rue et c'est le gouvernement qui a fait
en sorte qu'il ne reste que la rue voilà
donc pour cette manifestation à paris
place de la république qui prend fin on
voit les forces de l'ordre qui se
replient et les manifestants vous les
voyez ici dans cette
bouche de métro donc ils font face aux
forces de l'ordre mais s'apprête donc à
quitter
place de la république et voyez c'est
plutôt une atmosphère calme 1 est plutôt
vivante qui règne dans cette bouche de
métro place de la république vous voyez
les manifestants à applaudir
il n'y a pas vraiment de tension là en
tout cas on se coupe on peut observer
avec les forces de l'ordre
on va rester sur ces images on va on va
rester sur ces images on voit les forces
de l'ordre qui ont donc enlevé leur
casque vous voyez
est ce un signe de réconciliation je
sais pas si on peut parler de
réconciliation entre les forces de
l'ordre les manifestants mais en tout
cas il ya aucune opposition ici et c'est
plutôt une image rassurante à l'issue de
cette journée de mobilisation dans toute
la france à lille à marseille à toulouse
et à paris où ça s'est quand même
globalement bien déroulé malgré des
petites tensions puisque les forces de
l'ordre avaient pour ordre de faire face
un des potentiels risques de profils
radicaux infiltrés dans le courtage et
et on voit ici donc on va rester sur ces
images un petit peu parce que c'est
important on a tellement montrer d'image
d'opposition entre les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants des images de
tension donc c'est bien aussi de montrer
ces images on voit que l'atmosphère est
plutôt joyeuse
voilà ça se passe donc du côté de la
bouche de métro république fabrice
grimal est toujours avec nous il est
entrepreneur auteur du livre la
révolution
peut-être que vous pouvez commenter avec
nous ces images
bien sûr je suis pas étonné de ce que je
vois déjà parce que les forces de
l'ordre gaz très très rarement dans le
métro c'est vraiment le chaos
et en plus de ça je vois des gendarmes à
l'image des cantons et gilet jaune on
sait que voilà on soit jamais le même
traitement de gendarmes et de crs
il ya eu des images terribles dans le
mouvement de la part de gendarmes je
pense notamment à l'épisode l'épisode
dettinger il ya eu des tirs
voilà malheureux de la part de gendarmes
est quand même globalement on sait à
présent de rue
voire plus pour certains que les
gendarmes sont toujours beaucoup plus
appréciés du public et et obéissent aux
ordres certes qui viennent de la
préfecture de police mais de manière
beaucoup plus intelligente peser et
gardent beaucoup plus l'armé au pied
et ils interviennent que s'ils sont
vraiment vraiment contraint donc c'est à
dire les gendarmes sont nos amis mais en
tous les cas voilà il ya beaucoup de
respect depuis le début entre les gilet
jaune légendes telles sont pas des réuni
1 c'est sûr non non non non et on voit
ce manifestant là avec cette pancarte
jaune vivre oui survivre non on voit
bien que cette mobilisation elle
concentre des manifestants qui ne sont
pas là seulement pour contester les lois
liberticides ça va bien au delà
oui oui le niveau de méfiance c'est elle
il l'était déjà avant le coc vides et
alors après je vous laisse imaginer que
voilà c'est un niveau de tension qu'on
n'avait jamais vu en france depuis qu'on
puisse vraiment très très longtemps
depuis plusieurs décennies lorsque les
grandes grèves de 95 concernait que
certaines catégories le mouvement du cpe
ne concernait que certaines catégories
c'étaient les mouvements qu'on peut
identifier du point de vue des syndicats
du point de vue des étudiants des foules
parfois des fonctionnaires mais c'est
vrai que voilà là c'est toute la france
depuis deux ans quel que soit le
prétexte et on en est là on en est là à
plus de mâcon
oui fabrice voilà on va écouter un petit
peu la marseillaise avec vous
storey mais d'image assez forte ces
manifestants qui chantent la
marseillaise en face donc à ces
gendarmes
cette unité
ils bloquent la bouche de métro
république pour empêcher les
manifestants évidemment de sortir de
rejoindre la place puisque
la dispersion est quasiment terminé sur
cette place de la république
[Applaudissements]
voilà fabrice kullmann en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes entrepreneur
auteur du livre vers la révolution merci
à vous